Netflix's deliciously dark adaptation of the
best-selling books A Series of Unfortunate
Events is absolutely loaded with easter eggs
and references.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm going to whip through
some of my favourite easter eggs, cameos,
and connections to TV shows, movies, and Lemony
Snicket's original books that I found in the
TV series.
Ok, quick warning: there are spoilers ahead,
so if you want to avoid those, look away,
look away!
But don't forget to come back here when you're
ready!
Before this show, actress Malina Weissman,
who plays Violet Baudelaire, was best known
for her role as the young Kara Zor-El in the
TV show Supergirl, and there's a great Supergirl
hat-tip in Part One of The Reptile Room.
Yes, when Violet and her siblings sit down
to eat with their guardian Dr Monty Montgomery
and Stephano, Violet asks, 'Could you please
pass the pot stickers?'
Which is a delicious reference to Supergirl's
love of that particular food, which we've
seen a number of times in the Supergirl TV
series!
If only Violet could have 'melted' Count Olaf's
face when he deliberately ate all the pot
stickers, the way that Kara jokingly told
her sister she'd do in Supergirl, then the
Baudelaire children wouldn't have had to deal
with all those unfortunate events!
During the tunnel scenes in the first episode,
Lemony Snicket walks past a variety of signs,
many of which are references to characters
in the original books, some of whom we'll
no doubt see in future seasons.
For example, there's a sign for JULIENNE,
which is a shout-out to Geraldine Julienne,
a reporter at The Daily Punctilio, where Eleanora
Poe is the Editor-in-Chief.
Speaking of which, although Julienne hasn't
appeared in the TV series yet, Eleanora Poe
does mention her 'star reporter' who wrote
a front-page feature about the Baudelaire
Mansion fire, and whose by-line we see on
another article about the Baudelaire children.
Another sign we see is for REMORA, which is
a reference to Mr Remora, a teacher at the
Prep School where Violet, Klaus and Sunny
find themselves at the end of season one.
And that's also where, in the book The Austere
Academy, the Baudelaires meet the very mean
schoolgirl Carmelita SPATS.
As for the sign for WIDDERSHINS, that refers
to Captain Widdershins, the step-father of
the Hook-Handed Man, who also gets a sign
in the tunnels featuring his name FERNALD.
There are also signs for characters who appear
in later episodes of season one, including
Montgomery, the children's guardian; Anwhistle,
the surname of the Baudelaire's guardian,
Aunt Josephine; Strauss, Count Olaf's neighbour
Justice Strauss; Snicket, a reference to writer-narrator
Lemony or his siblings Jacques and Kit; and
Quagmire, the surname of Cobie Smulders and
Will Arnett's mother and father characters
whose children end up at the same school as
the Baudelaires.
Over the course of season one of the show,
there are a number of nods to All The Wrong
Questions, a collection of four books that
serve as a prequel to the Series of Unfortunate
Events novels.
In episode 3, Klaus asks Violet, 'How did
he find us?'
when Count Olaf turns up disguised as Stephano
at Uncle Monty's house, to which Violet replies,
'That's the wrong question.'
And in episode 7, after the children discuss
whether Count Olaf will find them at the mill,
narrator Lemony Snicket says, 'Violet was
asking the wrong questions.'
Also, in episode 2, when Violet and Klaus
are looking for their missing sister, Sunny,
the dastardly Count asks them, 'When did you
see her last?', which is actually the title
of the second book in the All The Wrong Questions
series.
In real life, Lemony Snicket is actually the
pen name for author Daniel Handler.
And, although actor Patrick Warburton plays
the part of Snicket on screen, Handler does
actually appear three times in the show as
well!
In episode 5, when Aunt Josephine is shopping
at the market, Handler pops up selling fish
heads at a street stall!
And in episode 6, as a storm's coming, he
runs across the street yelling 'save the fish
heads!'
Then in episode 7, he makes another appearance,
this time interacting with Mr Poe, who's desperate
to find the Baudelaire children, who he doesn't
realise have run away to the Lucky Smells
Lumbermill.
Mr Poe looks at the camera and cries 'It's
a catastrophe!
It's unprecedented!
It's off-book!
It's unfortunate!', then he turns to Handler's
fish-head seller and says, 'The Baudelaires
are lost and unsupervised!
Do you know what that means?', to which Handler
replies, 'Without supervision.'
This is an ingeniously meta moment as, in
the original books, Mr Poe knows exactly where
the children are because he takes them to
Paltreyville where the Mill is to meet their
next guardian, so that part of the story in
the TV series has quite literally gone 'off-book'!
In Part Two of The Wide Window, after Count
Olaf has forced Josephine to write a will
leaving the children in his care, she rushes
into her library to try to figure out a means
of escape.
And when Olaf, who's disguised as Captain
Sham at the time, notices that Josephine has
shut the library doors behind her, he hobbles
up the hallway after her, saying 'Here's Shammy!'
Which is an homage to Stanley Kubrick's movie
The Shining and Jack Nicholson's famous line,
'Here's Johnny', which he says as he breaks
down the door to the bathroom where his character's
wife is hiding.
In 2004, the first three books in Lemony Snicket's
A Series of Unfortunate Events were adapted
into a movie starring Jim Carrey as Count
Olaf.
And, like Netflix's version of the Baudelaires'
story, that movie featured the character of
Justice Strauss, who was played by an actress
called Catherine O'Hara, whose name should
ring a bell if you've watched the closing
credits of A Series of Unfortunate Events
on Netflix as this time Catherine O'Hara plays
the scheming optometrist Dr Georgina Orwell
in the show!
Which adds another meta layer of humour to
the scene where Dr Orwell tells Klaus about
an optometrist who changed her looks 'to assume
a new identity in a faraway town'.
In the season finale, there's a lovely easter
egg to the books as well as a tease for season
two when our narrator Lemony Snicket explains
hypnosis to us, saying that, 'The 'Encyclopedia
Hypnotica tells of […] a man who, upon hearing
the word "Nero," could suddenly play an instrument
he'd never studied.'
Then the camera cuts to a woman playing a
violin in a movie that Snicket's watching
on TV.
This is a nice nod to the character of Vice
Principal Nero, who runs the boarding school
where we see the Baudelaire children at the
end of season one.
In the books, Vice Principal Nero is a nasty
character and an awful violin player who forces
students to listen to his performances.
His name and violin obsession were likely
inspired by the Roman Emperor Nero and the
expression 'Nero fiddled while Rome burned.'
And, towards the end of the eighth episode,
we also see the silhouette of a person playing
the violin, again, letting us know that we'll
be seeing Vice Principal Nero in season two.
Of course, there are tons more easter eggs
and references in the show, but what were
your favourites?
And what are you looking forward to seeing
in season 2 and who would you like to see
cast in some of the new roles?
I'd love to hear your ideas in the comments
below!
If you enjoyed this video, do please like
and share it, and subscribe for more of my
easter egg videos and amazing movie and TV
secrets.
You can click or tap here for more videos
you might like!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!